in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ross
and Katie are with us hey guys how are
you hey Dave they are awesome how are
you sir I am better than I deserve
welcome welcome where are you guys from
we are from Verona Wisconsin just
outside of Madison fine and who are the
two babes with you in my arms here I
have Benjamin who's two and a half and
we have Kendrick over here who is what
eight eight weeks old eight weeks
Wow that's a little one to be hauling on
the road all the way from Madison
Wisconsin they were champs coming down
here I'm telling you well that's cool
very fun well thanks for making the trip
you're here to do your debt free scream
how much have you paid off we have paid
off shade over two hundred and seventy
seven thousand dollars oh oh did that
take about four and a half years Wow
making what kind of money around a
hundred okay and is that your house that
is their house or else new so how old
are you - I am now 31 yeah and I turned
thirty two days ago and you have paid
for house you guys are officially weird
we love it we love doing weird man
that's amazing what's the house worth Oh
probably probably around 320 now I think
somewhere in there cuddly yep
and you ever paid for house yeah don't
believe its kind of feel just strange at
30 years old it's great it's like we're
out of a fog we didn't even know we were
in yeah the rest your life to build
wealth and give oh my god I mean you're
gonna be so rich it's gonna being crazy
that's nuts man
you've cut you've changed your family
tree you start you Peter save a house
players ten million dollars yeah oh my
gosh oh man it is so cool we just we
just love the fact that you're doing
you're doing this work you've changed
our life you've changed her life you
showed us the way sir and we serve did
the work will own that but we appreciate
your leadership in that regard well I'm
honored because her heat rose this is
amazing
so uh what happened four and a half
years ago well I was cleaning my garage
one day it's we first heard about yeah
at least 25 years old sweep in the
garage no kids is Saturday whatever do
summer cleaning or something than
sweeping
garage and there's this weird guy named
Dave Ramsey radio and I start listening
and I'm like man that kind of makes
sense like it's so simple is that is it
really that easy and so I mentioned it
to Katy and it just so happens that you
know Katy was having some other thoughts
at that time as well yeah that year we
got in a really big tax return and we
decided that was a good time to put a
deck on the back of our house because
the tax return would pay for that and
then for her birthday and Christmas we
bought a house full of carpet for Ross's
mom which was great and we put that on a
Home Depot credit card and then all the
bills for everything started coming due
at the same time and we're realizing
we're kind of broke like we can't pay
for all this at the same time so we were
starting to get a little worried about
it
and that's when Rochard program right I
heard you in the garage mentioned it to
Katy that Christmas we go to Florida for
a family vacation we hit my in-laws
brought us down there was awesome but
Katy gives me a total money makeover and
we're sitting out on the beach reading
the book and realizing you know we
probably shouldn't be in Florida right
now we should probably be at home not
spending money you know we started that
following January and just this August
finished Wow
I mean you've not you know you walked
out of the Home Depot card and the other
stuff and then build your emergency fund
right up the baby steps the Total Money
Makeover and then start a hammering on
baby step six four and a half years
later houses it's just wow that's great
just wow so when you started this
process that January after the beach and
after the book on the beach when you
were looking up at the mountain versus
now you're standing on the mountain
looking down was it harder or easier
than you thought when you think back on
your emotions in that January when you
first started I think starting off it
was it was more difficult but not me
when you look back was that was the
journey out of that house and everything
easier than you thought it was going to
be or harder than you thought it was
going to be it's easier easier Dave and
we were talking about the some of the
way down it's really easier because I
think we had a change in spirit ah just
in terms of what we value
and the sense of contentment that comes
along with just getting your house in
order I mean no pun intended but getting
your house in order and realizing that
stuff is never gonna make you happy and
if you're and if you're in that you know
chasing stuff you're never gonna have
enough stuff to really feel fulfilled
yeah and so that that sort of change in
spirit I mean it's obviously still
difficult you know making the sacrifices
along the way and not going out to eat
or whatever
not if people make fun of you oh sure
yeah no doubt you know and just being
weird I mean I guess we're weird and in
the few few ways whenever it's our
finances or the way we plan to school or
kids at home school or something like
that but you know but people look at you
when they just kinda what are you doing
you know and you look back at them and
you ask them the same thing what are you
doing yeah yeah it's just yeah
amen amen that's a good answer I like
that that's good well congratulations
you guys you're incredible very you just
rock star couple man this is neat you
guys do this you can do anything
this is serious absolutely amazing very
very well done
all right Ross and Katie Benjamin and
Kendrick from Madison Wisconsin two
hundred and seventy seven thousand
dollars paid off that includes their
house in four and a half years making a
hundred a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two one
well done you two very very very well
done
awesome awesome awesome